[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is Jason
Muse Jay from Silent Bob and Jay from
clerks all of the clerks's uh clerks's
the clerks Trilogy Dogma Chasing Amy
he's also warm funny kind interesting
I'm so glad you guys are here a couple
things before we jump in I am currently
touring thank you to everybody that came
out in St Louis and I really hope to see
people in Raleigh North Carolina uh this
coming weekend I'm sure tickets I'm not
I'm hoping tickets aren't still
available but you just caught me being
like I'm sure tickets are still
available uh a lot of people will buy
them last minute go to petehomes.com it
means so much that people are coming out
after that is going to be Utah uh we're
gonna somebody message me or like
where's Indiana Indiana will be
announced it'll be on there soon
um but all of the tour dates will be at
pethomes.com as they unravel so uh it
means so much it's a new hour
I have a special coming out at the end
of October so that will be one hour and
then after that this is the new hour so
I'm excited to already be touring that
and it's really really fun and people
are enjoying it so I hope you can make
it out there only one thing to plug up
top and it's our friends at Living
Libations living Libations is a hair
skin eyes teeth a beauty care company
that has changed the way I look at
Beauty care Beauty care that's what I'm
going to call the the market but you
know things you put on your body end up
in your body and so many things we put
on our body are toxic they're filled
with chemicals they're made by
corporations that don't care about you
whatsoever and I fell for it I fell for
the marketing I was like it's got a
French name or it's it's expensive so it
must be good for my skin nonsense you
should recognize the ingredients on your
skin care in the same way you should
recognize the ingredients of your food
because what you're putting on your body
gets in your body the living Libations
is here to help not only is it natural
with things you can pronounce and
understand but it's bad ass it works
it's the best exfoliant I've ever used
it's the best moisturizer I've ever used
they have gum Care Dental Care they have
baby care I always mention that we use
their love the sun sunblock because it's
the only actually clean zinc based
sunblock that I've found and it works
you can buy a little bottle it'll last
you a really really long time so living
Libations is a great way to support the
show we only endorse things that I
actually use and actually love living
Libations is one of those so if you want
to show some love to this show if you
enjoy the show go to livinglibations.com
weird you'll get 15 off everything you
see there you can just get a tongue
scraper scrape your tongue that's
something I didn't figure out until I
was in my 30s scrape your tongue don't
just brush your teeth scrape your tongue
get some sunblock get some skin care get
some eye care whatever it is that you'd
like to replace and slowly up your
medicine cabinet game just get something
little or do what I did and do a
complete overhaul it makes a difference
it supports the show I personally
appreciate it and do your body a favor
go to
livinglibations.com weird 15 off
everything on site you get a premium
natural and wonderful product to replace
the random chemical neon blue nightmare
that they sell at 7-Eleven living
libations.com weird alright everybody
enjoy the chat with Jason Muse hope to
see you in North Carolina this weekend
get
into it welcome hi thank you so I'm
admiring the the place you know I had
um a cool setup but we just moved uh
well not just moved I guess it's been
like 10 months and we have a garage that
we plan on
doing this too
um I love that this is a this I feel
like look they did a great job and uh
but I'm not I didn't know we were this
status like you could say we want to do
this yeah yeah that's great because I
see other Studios and sometimes they're
all reclaimed wood and neon and stuff so
this is at home so it's it's great it's
uh you know again it's like if you have
an I know you have like if you go to an
office and then they're gonna put you
know you could you have more options but
this is yeah you have to come hang out
in the back room well it's cozy we used
to do it on that couch there so you me
and the guests were literally on the
same couch and that was that was kind of
nice it just looked like [__] on camera
okay so it changed every once in a while
I'm sure someone put their hand down
they're like oops sorry
well I was always kicking the guess I
was always doing that for fun for
funsies we were just so my daughter you
just met my daughter yes we're going to
Disneyland today and I want I want to
fold you in on this she's fine well
she's gonna be five in September and it
was like can you go on Pirates of the
Caribbean when you're five
do you think because there's that drop
there's a drop I think you can do it
it's more about the the height you know
it's it's funny because we have an
eight-year-old oh my gosh and we just
went to Disney again and she was so
excited because the bummer is
and I don't know if you're bringing
friends but she has a friend that's the
same age she's three weeks older only
but I swear she's about a foot and a
half taller yeah and she's built like
because the parents are both and so even
though the same age you look at them and
the one her friend is like again so so
her friend was able to go on the Harry
Potter ride
I don't know if it's Universal Disney
but her friend was able to go on the
Harry Potter ride and she wasn't able to
your daughter my daughter and she was so
bummed but we just brought up for her
birthday this year and she was able to
go
um and she was very excited about that
so I'm just saying I don't think it's a
matter of it's hype yeah but like
emotional emotionally you need to be
scared at fun like I don't want to
traumatize it I let okay let cat out of
bag I went on Pirates when I was
probably
11. and that drop I remember being like
I really remember like a like an old
woman being like I didn't care for that
like being like it was do like no one
tells you that there's that drop yeah
and I also remember there's the skeleton
in the Pirates this is before the movies
too so it wasn't like cartoonized yeah
yeah like Johnny Depp made it seem so
yeah to be a like a Pillager and you
know no yeah he made it fun and the
other one yeah running out wheels and
stuff yeah yeah exactly he made it fun
or if I wonder if if the drought would I
mean I guess it depends I I don't know
if I tell her though yeah if you've worn
her and said yeah I think you know and
even if she gets well I don't know it is
a tough one it's a tough one you know
I'll let you know we're going to be best
friends and I'm going to keep you in
touch and I'll text you please because
I'm curious because it's like either
she's gonna love it want to go on it a
bunch of times yeah she'll get really
terrified yeah and then maybe be very
disappointed in you forever
she's like traumatized and she blames me
right buddy what were those for you mine
was good Fellas my dad was just watching
Good Fellas and I've said this on the
Pod before but they opened the trunk and
they stab the guy yes yes stabbings are
not cool for some reason guns seem so
fake yeah it's stabbing he probably
really was stabbing something it sounds
yeah because it's the sound the Foley
guy in a in a quiet Studio stabbing like
lamb chops yeah just being like is that
juicy enough yeah crazy it is different
you know she hasn't
I don't know if I've done anything yet
oh I meant for you for you I wouldn't I
wouldn't want to embarrass you what's
your name for me oh for me what's
traumatizing to me either yeah no like
those little things that your dad or
your mom probably didn't know my mice
have put me in a closet and shoot dope
outside
you can't follow my Good Fellas
wait okay let's unpack it yeah do it it
sounds like you're okay you've done that
at this point yeah you know the fun
thing is Kevin and I did a live podcast
um we didn't we didn't really touch on
that as much but we did a podcast for
about nine years and we do it live and
we would talk about it was mainly about
me at my
um addiction and being accountable and
and hey I have two years sober now I
have three years sober it was a lot of
fun yeah we we haven't been doing it
really we've done it now at a couple
comic conventions but we don't touch so
much on the sobriety because now July
2nd I had 13 years sober oh wow but in
the beginning like you know 13 years ago
it was nice because I had like three
months sober we started the podcast and
it was almost you know like traveling
and talking about it really helped my
process because that because then I'd be
in like Starbucks and so on be like hey
man how many days sober do you have you
know right so like people would call me
out all the time so it helped because
then I'd like dream that I was like I
seriously would have dreams that I drank
and I'd have to get on stage and tell
everyone I only have one day today you
know and it wouldn't be disappointed
drinking the week I got married so my
non-drinking anniversary is my wedding
day yeah and I So every anniversary that
we celebrate is also my I don't drink
aversary yeah yeah and I haven't really
been tempted but I'm also like I don't
want to throw away the coolest and
easiest anniversary yeah I know that
sounds stupid but like no it's good Let
Me unpack what you were also saying too
for me a lot of my alcoholism and
addiction stuff has been because I feel
invisible right there's this like
invisible I don't exist sort of feeling
so like I'm alone so let's just take
care of the only thing that I have which
is which is me so it can be kind of
lonely so opening that up to people
which can be risky but when they're kind
of co-conspirators in your health and
your Wellness they're also seeing you
you know what I mean it's not just that
they know you're sober yeah but they're
like pulling for you and if I were you
that would help me feel less
it definitely is true and again it was
it was like again because also people
would share like oh my gosh you know I
was uh you know I was struggling I just
I tried to get sober and then I started
listening to podcasts and every time I
felt like using I would listen to a
couple episodes and I'd get through the
day and now I have two months so yeah
like there's all these different Avenues
people would like I'd be accountable to
them but also disappointing them and but
and then but sharing the stories and
stuff so it was it was again many
different Avenues plus Kevin and my wife
of course because my wife's the one who
was booking all the touring like hey
you're going to Australia and you're
doing five shows and yeah you know yeah
Adelaide or whatever so it was nice it
really was and and again I think there's
some stuff I because of that it was
helping me but at the same time I wasn't
going to meetings and for me I I started
doing them again recently because I feel
like there was some stuff as much as I
talked about I wasn't working on like
again going back to my parents like I
wouldn't sit on stage because it would
be Kevin and I telling stories and plus
I want to entertain you want to
entertain the audience doesn't have to
be funny yeah so so I'll tell old
stories but I can make light of it now
and and I had to like try to make it
animated and quick and I couldn't get
into like hey man like I remember this
one time and get really deep into
getting locked in the closet or blah
blah yeah so those are things I mean you
know it didn't help me with that but
again I think meetings and sharing and
doing the steps and all that as well all
that stuff sort of helps it's been good
there's a lot of I love everything you
just said and I heard it and it made me
think of how there's all this data about
like community and having one another
helps with all sorts of problems right
and we are more isolated and I think
it's funny that podcasts as high tech as
this is and I've said this kind of idea
before but you know know as a podcaster
it's also really low Tech yeah like you
and I are now getting together and
having like a long heartfelt
conversation and we didn't used to do
that and it helps me be healthy in a lot
of ways and it helps me it sounds like
it helped you yeah stay clean no it's
it's okay live in a village you know
what I mean like it used to be in a
village and you didn't want to be the
guy in the village like we would see you
if you used or whatever or you would
disappear and we would notice yeah and
there's something very like not helpful
that you can vanish and we might just
not know yeah you know what I mean no
for sure like it used to be unacceptable
would go like but we first of all that
you we would need you but we need Jason
we're going to get fish or whatever you
know what I mean so that made you in you
know a meshed in the community and now
now you know it's not exactly the best
thing in the world that we can just go
like
I haven't seen you in six months yeah no
there was a there was a point where uh
Kevin got a phone call and it's so crazy
because he found it recently uh the
newspaper clipping or I'm actually my
aunt sentenced me but there was a point
where a newspaper Kevin said he was at
his desk he I had disappeared and
the he got a call saying hey do you have
any comments on the death of your friend
Jason oh God so yeah like and it was
like People magazine or something but
they thought I had died and it was even
in the newspaper my aunt clipped it out
but because
yeah they thought I had died in OD'd on
on drugs yeah so again you're right it's
like it's such Everything Has Changed I
mean the internet like uh Instagram and
all this stuff it's such a deal even
that people would kind of notice yeah
like on online yeah so on one hand it
seems so strange and then this other
more subtle and not as big way it is
sort of connecting these ways that's
crazy so tell me okay let's let's talk
about closet closet so yeah I think you
remember it yeah there was a time a
point there was one time uh that I
remember and the reason is is because I
was so I was in went to New York my mom
drove me to New York and we went into
the projects I remember this like really
dingy dark apartment
um and my mom puts me in the closet and
says I'll be I'll come get you in one
minute two minutes and all I remember
hearing is like a little bit of quiet it
was really quiet and then all of a
sudden throwing up and it in like some
weird sounds and I thought something bad
was going on it was really bad so like I
was like freaking out in there and said
finally she opened it up and then I
realized she was throwing up because she
had used drugs but at first it sounded
like you put that together yeah yeah I
knew exactly yeah I knew how old are you
around this time you know I don't know I
wish I wish I could remember
blocked out stuff me and my wife were
talking about the other day because we
were we were trying to figure out my
daughter remembering stuff and all this
um and I was like man I don't have many
childhood memories I feel like until
high school because I think we were
talking about you know the the weirdest
thing happened and I'm all over the
place but you're fine my kid is in third
grade now she's eight but last year she
had this best friend and they were
hanging out and all that stuff and then
one day she like comes home she asks us
to pick her up early and she's in tears
and her friend doesn't want to be
friends with her anymore and we thought
oh you know it'll blow over but then the
next day I bring her to school and we
walk up and there's this like little
event party going on and she comes and
sits by her friend and her friend
doesn't say a word to her then my
daughter walks away and I said hey you
want to go play with Logan on the slide
or anything and she's like no I don't I
can't do that I don't want to do that
and it broke my heart like your
daughter's name Logan yes sorry and her
friend I don't want to see her friend's
name
yeah yeah no my daughter 's Logan
so heartbroken and I didn't realize how
much it would affect me like yeah and it
really like hurt my feelings and I'm
like do I talk to her mom I'm gonna talk
to find out what's going on and talk to
her dad like is there something wrong
did Logan do something really bad that
made her feel like because again it
wasn't even like I've seen over the
years with their friends they getting
their little tit and they don't talk and
they're mad this is straight up like in
a diced ice drop like seriously the next
five times we saw her just won't say
hello she'd run up hi though good
morning and she would just look at her
and walk away like iced her out on a
hundred percent got bad chills yeah and
it really broke my heart seeing it and I
didn't know what to do and I didn't know
what that would affect me so much but I
mentioned that because I realized like
they haven't finished
this year she's now talked to her a few
times and she wasn't doing the same
thing that we saw her okay school's only
been on for three days the first three
days I dropped her off she went up and
they were talking so it seems okay it
seems okay yeah yeah but sorry I was
like I wonder if she's gonna remember
this so many years later and me and my
wife were talking about I was like I
don't remember stuff from second grade I
feel like the first thing memories I
have of school and remembering is sixth
grade for somebody like anything under
that you're sort of blowing my mind
because listen to this I went to Disney
probably world because we were East
Coast kids Disney World when I was
little and I said to my mom I saw this
kid crying like a little kid crying and
I said to my mom and this is so I really
I'm excited to see what this makes you
think of I said to my mom mom when I was
little and I was crying why didn't you
just say you won't even remember this
and I thought that was like brilliant
like I had uncovered like memory yeah
and how it works and I go you you could
have said like you won't even remember
this and she goes I did and I was like I
just didn't believe her like my mom
didn't like let me have the point she
was like I did and I was like doesn't
sound no I don't know why I don't
believe you that was a feeling of my
childhood was I felt like I was having
all these epiphanies yeah and you're
Kevin Smith when he did the Pod said
you're one of the most original and
you're so wildly creative I was
wondering if you have any memories of
being like is anyone else noticing that
I'm you know twinkling over here and
people are just like yeah Jay eat your
pastrami or whatever no I you know what
I know I feel like I was super you know
I feel like for me I was super insecure
and I think that's why I was as much as
I felt like again I was telling my my
kid I try to give her any advice I have
for her I feel like it's for me from
high school and so I was like listen you
got to treat others I realized as I got
older I would treat kids how I wanted to
be treated I'd be nice and you know the
chess kids the football kids the the emo
like you were the United Nations
was what would invite me to parties and
invite me out that way too yeah and but
they'd always go don't bring your
friends so and so you know what I mean
so I my friend it's true and I remember
being like so uncomfortable because I'd
want to go to this party but I feel so
bad soap and not bringing my two friends
that I hung out with more than with the
actual other kids they were actually my
friends and I told my kid I was like
just make sure you treat everyone like
that but but again but I think that I
was so outgoing and and obnoxious and
because I felt like insecure like again
I always felt like yeah yeah I always
felt like you know I had the smallest
penis in the room and yeah all this
stuff I remember all these like weird
things but not weird things but just
weird things like getting like really
thinking like man I have a small penis
man I bet everyone else has way bigger
penis that dress is better than me yeah
you went right to Dick yeah like Freud
would be very proud but most people
would be like wouldn't want to look at
what they're actually afraid of but it
just comes down to the it really was a
big thing for me and I think because my
brother would like flick my wiener and
stuff when I was sleeping
but you know it's it's interesting
because I tell my wife we have a son now
he's six months old oh my God and so
every time
and I'm always like yo look at this I'm
like look at this wiener I'm like you
know it's gonna be pretty big I think
and she's like why does it matter I'm
like you don't understand
wait do you really have a do you feel
like you have a small penis
I I mean again I'd like to say it's
average but I don't know I you know back
then too honestly I think my friends are
super I had the two three friends that
were not invited to anyways I remember
they'd whip their wieners out and stuff
and I remember them always being bigger
than mine yeah
they were bigger yeah we never showed
our like boners I don't know you never
know any boys that were like let's get
rock hard and yeah yeah no one ever
maybe they were fluffing that could be
you could have been batting it around a
little bit yeah you never know if the
guy who suggests hey let's show each
other our dicks knew said that because
he was starting to get a bonus oh this
is a good time to watch the show and
there's a little blood flow and little
yeah see I have really big balls yeah
nice it's not cool no yeah
exactly my friends used to joke that it
was like this and then yeah because I
went to this weird Christian college and
it's very like like that that sort of
adolescent boy thing if you're I'm gonna
say in my case a repressedly sexually
repressed religious kid
and you're in an all-boys dorm that sort
of weird like let's show Dick's stuff
continues past junior high or whatever
adolescence so everyone was like Peach
they called me Buffalo heart they're
like Pete Buffalo are showing the
Buffalo people put dicks on your
shoulder and stuff it was very I don't
know if the military is that way but I
imagine so and do you think
going back would you do you feel like
you
it was a good thing he went to all boys
or you think there was girls around him
it wasn't all boys just the dorms oh the
dorm was all but there were rules that
we weren't allowed I but to answer your
question which is generous uh it's a
good question I I did appreciate that at
my school there wasn't drinking and
there wasn't it was very difficult to
have sex some people were having sex
yeah yeah but I just didn't get into it
because it was it was like literally you
couldn't be in other people's rooms you
couldn't close the door if a girl was in
your room and because of that especially
because I didn't figure out I was an
alcoholic until I was 22. I got through
all of those brain growing years without
if I'd gotten interviews I might have
like really loved it and I don't know if
I would have been as bored as I was and
when I got bored that's when I started
doing comedy it's like the power of of
boredom so so wait you went all four
years or whatever it is of college so
you went to college yeah what was the
plan uh uh to be when you were faster
and then became and then but like three
months in I was like I'm not gonna hear
you like I just immediately because I
thought it was going to be like a
monastery like people walking around and
be like hello brother rope belt and like
yeah it wasn't it was just a very normal
for the most part school yeah and I
sound like an old person but it didn't
have the party scene yeah and it was
kind of good it was good yeah so you got
work done you were able to do all that
stuff and the work was easy yeah like
not to put the school down but to me I
was like this is pretty this is easier
than my high school yeah so then all I
did was like you know start an improv
team and start doing stand-up and stuff
but this is interesting when did you
start using when or or when did you
start drinking what did it start with so
mine was um
you know it's funny because my mom my
mom was using and winded up single mom
going to jail yeah I never met my father
never so I have two a brother and a
sister such a weird long thing I'll try
to be fast about this
um my my sister and I so my mom had my
brother who's eight years older but
couldn't take care of him so my aunt
took them in at like eight months old
because my mom went to jail
yeah for drugs but like it was like an
eight-month thing when she got out eight
months later said hey we I can't take
care of the boy will you adopt them so
my aunt adopted my brother so she was
taking care of him already yes he was
already taking care of them and my mom
realized going to jail and all that she
wasn't gonna be able to take care of him
yeah so my aunt
adopted my brother at like you know 16
months old uh and so he wasn't with us
but we got to see him he was like in the
family yeah did you know it was your
brother I did I did I knew it wasn't one
of those no it wasn't that but what I
didn't realize is my aunt was really my
cousin my grandma was really mine yeah
so there is some of that a lot of that
yes but not with the brother I thought
you were like no no no we didn't do that
but my mother was my cousin's aunt's
sister and I was like that was crazy all
that was crazy my and but I didn't know
either that for a little bit so I got
older and realized that my brother
sister and I have different fathers we
never none of us met our fathers
um oh boy but my sister and I grew up
with my mom in like the same household
and my mom got would get strung out
would disappear and my grandma would
take care of us
um and then we lived my grandma for a
year and two years and my mom would get
sober and take us back and back and
forth yeah but never met my dad so I was
with my grandma my aunt raised me my mom
raised me at some point my mother then
goes to jail for like nine years 10
years for what um for for selling heroin
um selling here yeah to make money to do
heroin yes so she started selling and
got busted
um I'm not trying to be funny I really
aren't or clever I have to imagine if
you love like Artie Lange and I did a
show together and we talked about his
heroin addiction and he was like it's
like air is what he said to me he was
like it's like someone telling you not
to breathe yeah when you're in
withdrawal and all that sort of stuff so
if you love heroin or are addicted to
heroin let's say that yeah
selling it so having a stash of it has
to be the most difficult thing in the
world I would imagine right and I think
that's where you get in the problems
right because then you're like supposed
to sell it and make this money because
you're getting it from someone's I'm
assuming my mom's getting it for someone
so I'd imagine she needs money to pay
this person there's someone chasing you
and you're gonna do some of it yeah
you're going to do something yeah that's
just how it is 100 so now you have to
overcharge someone yeah the the
Heartbreak of it and the desperation and
the humanity of it like it's so
vulnerable it's like one of the most
vulnerable things I can imagine so she's
in this situation she gets caught yes
and then she runs off but what happens
is so because she doesn't get busted and
so I'm 12 years old I'm about to ride my
bike over to my buddy's house hey
um bring this to your sorry there's a
kid in town I know he was friends with
my older brother bring this to so and so
him and his uncle need this and they owe
me money I didn't know what it was it
was like an envelope it was like one of
those big yeah Manila almost so I'm
thinking it's paperwork or something and
she goes but he owes me some money from
like I lent the money a while ago make
sure he gives you 200 bucks or whatever
it was so I go down there give it boom
come back give my mom the money go to my
friend's house don't think on anything
of it too much later two months later my
brother Drive picks me up goes hey you
know when you met so-and-so there was
drugs and that was an undercover cop
with them it wasn't his uncle so my mom
ran but they were like we're gonna
charge her 12 year old son with did not
me yeah selling if you don't wait you
were on the hook yeah I was on the hook
for her because she ran and they didn't
have any proof that I didn't know what I
was doing first of all deep apologies
for stealing your punchline
you found out that she was using you to
mule and there was a cop there yes and
they said we're going to arrest your son
yes if you don't come turn yourself in
okay I'm again not trying to be clever
or funny but she must have been like
okay I go to jail it's gonna be how long
were the 18. it was about I think it was
like nine or ten nine or ten years yeah
again
what a terrible choice to be like but
you know Jason will just go to juvie and
you're strung out so that's what they
see me Dope Sick yeah oh my God and
going yeah yikes what happened so she
will end up turning herself in and
that's a big move yeah so she turned
herself in I didn't get in trouble thank
goodness but of course the cops in town
looked at me always weird for a while
except for like two because we lived in
this small town so there were like two
cool cops yeah there's like two cool
cops that never harassed me but there
was other ones who just thought oh
there's a guy a kid who sells drugs a
couple of my friends that I grew up with
their parents didn't want me hanging out
with them because you were labeled
newspaper and everything in town we
lived in this small town it was like a
mile long everyone knew your name was in
the newspaper Jason music I don't know
if they were allowed to put my name but
I I feel like they described me really
well yeah like again it was small enough
that everybody knew maybe they said my
mom's name and then put her son I'm not
sure
um it was so again I'm 49 now it's so
crazy that I'm pointing out at this
point yeah but anyway so it was it was
uh it was so so I hated so because of
that and because of her and and in the
situation I hated drugs I remember my
friend at like 14 asked me to do Coke
and I was like no way I hate that stuff
I wouldn't smoke cigarettes I didn't
drink or anything I then started
drinking probably at like 7 16 17 and I
started to smoke a little weed I
consider that like I'm changing or why
do to me in my head I felt like drinking
because it wasn't illegal wasn't that
bad and everyone partied and stuff and
then same with smoke can weed I just
didn't find weed to be good but anything
harder than that coke heroin actually
that weed was okay yeah I thought weed
was okay and I so I used smoke weed and
I used to drink but I never will do
cocaine
um or heroin I hate it I hate it right
no pills are bad yeah and 21 years old
um it's my birthday I had met this girl
who was way above my weight class I mean
honestly I saw her the first time her
friend they were best friends started
dating a guy that I was really good
friends with and worked with putting
roofs on houses and he introduced me and
I'm like this girl is like a model like
super beautiful I've never there's no
way and we started hooking up then my
birthday comes I'm like great for
yourself yeah I was like I'm like yeah
definitely 100 yeah
um and then I'm going 21 we could go to
a bar let's go out and we'll celebrate
my birthday and they're like nah man
we're gonna like just let's hang out
watch a movie and stuff and I'm like all
right I get a chance to hang out with
this girl my buddy he then tells me hey
to be honesty we've been doing this
because I was always wondering they
always would be like do it nodding and
doing something and I sort of knew but
didn't know I was trying like
um that's the feeling of adolescence
you're new to the world even though
you're 18 you're 21 at this point yeah
you're still kind of new and they sort
of kept that doing it away from me they
never went to get it or did it around me
yeah but they would come pick me up and
they'd be sleepy and I worked on my
buddy I know we'd be busting our butts
Roofing and stuff I'm not trying to be
funny again I'm going to stop saying I
just know that I'm not trying to make
fun of addiction or anything no no for
sure who's doing heroin and then running
around with their friends is that what
people do on heroin well they yeah well
they'd like pick me up and they'd want
to like go to the movies or do stuff
yeah yeah in the beginning until you
start getting to the experience yeah
when you get strung out and and uh you
start running out of money and stuff
then you stop doing that then it's like
you wake up how am I gonna get it where
am I like how much you want to do money
for it yeah yeah well you know you still
don't mind doing it with people because
you want someone misery loves company
you want someone that maybe tomorrow
you'll find money but I won't or today
I'll find money because you know what I
found my old camera and we could sell it
right we can get dope so it is you want
to run around with someone when you get
that bad but yes you're right you're not
going to movies you're not doing
anything it's not like let's go to
dinner on heroin or is it in the
beginning it was for me when I first
started 21st birthday really quick yes
I'm like I'll never do it this they go
we're gonna do this I'm like come on man
like um I can drink let's drink and I'm
21 let's go out and do something like no
man we're just gonna do this and I'm
like you know I don't get it and they're
like well you'll never get it unless you
did it before yeah and I'm like you know
what let me try I said give me some I'm
gonna try it I want to know what makes
you guys think this is worth not coming
out on my birthday and going now good
question at this point for them are they
enthusiastically endorsing it or are
they addicted to it they're addicted to
it but not strung out to them acts like
where they started doing it weekends and
here and there at this point they're
getting to that point where they're
doing it but they still have money to
buy it and not you know it's not ruining
them it's not ruining it yet but
um that failed that happens quickly of
course especially when you start adding
cocaine and doing speed balls and
cracking right um so I try it I lay with
it I snort it yeah I was like of course
after I snorted it I lay with her and I
cuddle it was amazing the feeling I'll
never forget it that moment yeah mean
that girl like you can tap into it I
mean yeah right of a feeling yes at that
point because I remember more so that
the laying with her like you know you
lay with someone and you have that
moment you're like you're like you know
you're like a mountain range maybe your
honeymoon your wife and you're like
you're married and I love this moment
but like you've really I felt like I was
like like falling in I felt like one and
it sounds emergency it doesn't sound
really dead it was it was it made that
euphoric feeling of like I already think
this girl's way beautiful than anyone
else I should do it yeah and now I'm
holding her and it was the most
comfortable look what happened those two
I'm not a neuroscientist but those two
like synapses are merged like your love
Yeah and your self-esteem yeah out of
your league as you said yeah girl this
woman and this drug experience
and those two needs are like being met
like you're probably your anxiety is
gone oh yeah Euphoria and you're like
with this person so it's just you know
It's Tricky when you you know when
alcoholics their first drink was with
their dad and it meant a lot yeah yeah I
mean It's Tricky when we blend those
needs it was it was it was so I'll never
forget in that first I was like all
right I get it now I totally get what
you guys are saying yeah about this but
you know I don't want to do it again and
of course like the feeling was great so
I'm like a week later two weeks later I
do it again with them and we do the same
thing and it's amazing and then it's
like a week later I do it again and that
so now I've done it like three times but
I'm like I'll never shoot it yeah but
then what happened can I ask yeah with
that this
is it bad to talk about what it feels
like is that inappropriate no no no no
because I'm just curious like what would
you liken it to yeah I don't I
mean I guess is it happiness or numbness
is it like it's Oblivion or is it like
my skin feels amazing well you know what
I'm saying like what is it in the
beginning it is that it's like well like
you said too there's no
you don't care if you feel
um you know like not seen you don't you
feel numb no pain no back pain no
whatever pain yeah so physically you
feel numb and even your head you just
feel like I don't care about anything I
just walked out of the building yeah
you're the building and you just walked
out yeah yeah again I don't know you
know
again I know if you've over the years if
you've ever broke a leg or got surgery
and when you went to the hospital they
shot you up with Demerol or morphine
yeah it's that feeling like you know
like also you're like my arm my arm and
then I'll send you like oh but it does
it feels like that in the beginning but
then it becomes such a crutch and and
again everybody yeah to be very clear
there's no part of me that's like I want
to do this no totally I've known people
so many people who've died we've all
known the epidemic all this stuff it's
crazy I don't mean the covet I mean the
heroin ever yes
so many people and that's the promise
again in my head I was like I can try it
once yeah and I'll won't do it again
in his book or some interview he hated
it the first time he did it made him
sick and I feel like it's a normal thing
to be like and I'm out because everyone
knows but there's some other undiagnosed
drive that's going to take you back to
it does that or just the hyper
addictiveness of it yeah I think the
dictate I and again I I have friends I
had a friend that used to run with me
and I do think it's true the disease of
addiction and stuff because
um I had a friend I swear he would use
with me like when I started getting
really bad he would pick me up and be
like Jay man we gotta get you help and
stuff like but all right before I get
help let's use and he would use at me
and he'd used twice and then he wouldn't
use for two months three months then I
would get out of rehab if I went or
whatever and I relapsed and he would try
to help me out again and we'd hang out
for a couple weeks and he would use a
couple times with me because I'd be like
well I'm not good anyway who's this man
this is like it was but I swear it was
unbelievable he would use and and be
able to stop it his generosity to hell
he he was a good dude he was he drove me
at one point I got really bad I was in
Cal I was out here in Cali
um I hadn't really seen Kevin or talked
to anyone I sort of disappeared because
I was so strung out I lived with this
girl
um and
um so I was still thinking about I feel
like I want to go back and then I'm
going to tell you that so really quick
with the because I was going with this I
thought oh man I'll never I won't I
won't I started doing on weekends I was
like I'll never shoot up my mom caught
AIDS I'll never use a needle and but
what happens is your tolerance gets so
like with anything it gets higher so
where I used to be able to feel normal
from ten dollar bag all of a sudden I
needed thirty dollars just to feel
normal and I only had 10 bucks this one
day and I was like oh I'm so sick and
this isn't going to help and I got this
one and so someone was like Hey if you
do it this way it'll work it goes
straight to your blood it doesn't
because nobody wants to snort it and go
there but it you know so I was still
like if you only have one if you shoot
it you won't need three bags you'll just
need one so I was like no way but this
person you know my mom got AIDS but
she's it was a nurse and she's like look
I have a Brand New Bag never opened of
syringes so in my head I'm like all
right this makes sense so anyway I'm
just saying even that's where like the
addiction's so strong that I something I
thought I'd never you definitely
understand because because honestly I'm
always compassion shopping I want more
compassion I keep thinking about father
Greg Boyle who I loved have you read
tattoos on the heart it's great it's
it's about Homeboy Industries this gang
rehab uh in L.A and he talks about like
standing in awe of what the poor have to
carry instead of in Judgment of how they
carry it so you just got me having like
a weird like yeah who wants to shoot up
needles and you help me bridge that it's
like it's because of a sickness and the
and lack of money and they have to you
know what I mean it's like a if I don't
do this meaning nobody likes it but you
see how that sort of vilifies or Monster
flies it's like there's these people
that like needles
and then even even sharing you wonder
like why would someone why were they
there because it's life or death yeah
well also because in the beginning you
might be able to get get a bunch of new
ones from the you know the needle
exchanges or this but when you're stuck
and you're sick and and you you're like
oh I have this one that so and so used
and it was in the trash but it's brand
new he used it once it's sharp yeah I'll
clean it out and use it or I won't clean
it out because I don't have anything to
clean it with and then you find yourself
doing that like it's crazy I'm watching
that show it comes up a lot alone it's
where they put people in the woods and
they have to live alone and when they
catch a fish and they're like but it
smells rotten but they eat it anyway
yeah it's the same it feels similar to
that it's like I'm gonna starve to death
if I don't yeah yeah so you're like this
smells like [__] I hope I don't get sick
and you're like maybe just go home but
like it's interesting no yeah I want to
check that out we you know what it was
so much fun I got to just do uh on on
Discovery Jack with Jack Osborne is go
look for bigfoot
which was a lot of fun sorry when you
said Woods afterwards we did not find
Bigfoot we heard some noises and got to
hear some cool stories but we and then
we did one uh we went to Skinwalker
Ranch so we did another one with Jamie
Kennedy and Jack Osborne what is
Skinwalker so it's in like I don't again
I keep getting them mixed up where I
went for to hunt for Bigfoot and that
but it's Utah or Ohio I'm always
confusing Idaho or Utah yeah sure um but
there's a ranch that I guess you know
what a skin Locker is yeah it's like
that they walk on this weird like you
know it's uh oh okay I think a beast
that like walks on all four and we were
we were looking for them because at this
Ranch there's supposed to be all this
weird stuff and uh the sightings of Skin
Walkers so we went and looked for
skinwalkers and then we got to it hasn't
come out yet but we went and uh we went
to this place called Ashmore Estates
where there's supposed to be ghosts and
stuff and we hunted for a ghost so my
point is it's so much fun like we have
to talk about all of that yeah dude it's
on the card I ask everybody about uh
ghost whoops my drink oh nice also
Skinwalker is I believe it's a Native
American term for someone in the tribe
that turns on the tribe yes which is so
I'm not yeah I'm gonna stop saying I'm
not everyone knows I'm not trying to be
funny so like when we have Shooters like
like uh active shooter things they're
like this isn't
I'm not saying it's it's a phenomena
it's a modern phenomena for sure but
they have this term like if somebody in
your own tribe turns on the tribe the
skinwalker okay that's what I heard I
mean yeah so yeah because well again
what what we got is yeah it's something
that like
can change from Human to like a beast or
something yeah yeah and yeah so I mean
again I'm sure there's many many and we
saw something on that we did we saw
something booked through this field it
really it's if you go watch the episode
you can see it we caught it on camera
you did yeah it's really awesome we
still don't know what it is I swear
yeah well we don't know if it was that
but whatever it was was like moving very
fast in like a shadow and it wasn't one
of our people that we were there with
because we were like over here base camp
we went out we started searching we got
our cameras and we were looking for
stuff and we were way far away from that
spot and we were like you know we're
looking with uh night vision goggles and
we had lights and all sorts of stuff to
look to see if we saw anything funny we
went to this spot where you're supposed
to see a lot of
uh activity in the sky and I swear also
in Jack's like look look and we all look
and I swear it was this weird [__] it
was so dark but there was like a shadow
and the thing was like moving super fast
and it wasn't any of our people yeah
it's still weird that that was that was
the one thing that I was like wow
you found one of the guys on the crew
was like uh you know uh he worked out
every day and he was very fit and he was
like he ran marathons and all this so
we're like try to walk as fast as you
can from there to there and we timed it
and he couldn't even like the most guys
could not walk as fast at the same speed
as this thing we saw like he did his
fastest to do it we timed it and we did
it like three times and he could not
match the speed of whatever we saw so
[Music]
and what about the ghost hunting uh that
was fun we heard things be you know
again nothing
I'll be honest nothing has really come
out we've saw some weird things we had
um we had a ghost box and I swear it's a
ghost box is like almost like a radio
you turn on it's like and it's like
staticky yeah it's like staticy but also
we're like we're we're like say
something if someone's here someone's
here and all of a sudden it was like
Jack it like sounded like whatever was
in there said Jack's name
um it was really cool you'll see in the
episode it was really really cool so
stuff like that happened but never have
I like I didn't see like something
floating that was like Json yeah yeah
have you ever I haven't I haven't you
know I I it would be awesome I mean you
seemed like a guy who may be seen a UFO
I don't know why
if I seen one I would believe me I but
it's I wonder I wonder if I if I saw it
with no proof right I could sit here for
days and be like listen I'm telling you
yeah I saw this thing and it was moving
um people might not believe you ever
since that article about you
but you know what they said I was dead
maybe I wasn't I'm a ghost right now
you're sitting across from a ghost my
friend yeah what's the difference
that's actually really interesting to me
it's like I saw something like that
exists yeah and like we exist yeah yeah
and we don't understand how we exists no
exactly but we are like ordinary ghosts
yeah that go around this work yeah how
does the heart work I always think every
time every time my wife has a baby it's
like insane yeah that that her body
starts the baby goes yeah all of a
sudden like she's it's it's been
incredible like were you there for the
birth yeah yeah for both well both of
our kids it's great you know honestly I
I feel blessed is is yourself what's
your same time Wolverine Lucian Lucy and
Logan and Lucian wait what's Lucy in a
reference to anything it's a French name
we just really like the name is Logan an
X-Men reference it is from Wolverine yes
and we knew before we had a boy or a
girl we're like if we have a kid we're
naming him Logan before the movie Logan
before the movies and all that good
things yeah my wife and I have been
together for 17 years but we've had a
comic book store Kevin and I for 25
years in Red Bank New Jersey his
daughter's name is Harley Quinn right
yes yeah yeah so the voice of Harley
Quinn just passed by the way the
animated series are like man I forget
her name forgive me but yeah it's anyway
that was just on my mind
um yeah what are you supposed to do with
that hey Jay that actress just passed
away no thanks
yeah yeah
99.99 yeah let's not say so close to a
dollar it's too soon I mean you know
it's like
it's I as much as people get set again I
was hard I I felt bummed what really
bummed when Stanley passed a huge fan I
got to meet him what a great man but he
was 96 right 97 yeah it's like and it's
like that's a good age that's why I you
know 90. the status of jokes right yeah
so someone dies and they're 99. we have
I've been talking with Val about this as
my wife a lot about how human beings are
really obsessed with Justice I did stand
up this weekend I make fun of my parents
and it works pretty well and if I give
them a little joke where they make fun
of me in it where they kind of win they
love it because it like balances the
scales but there's also a similar
consideration when it's like someone
died that was 99. so if Bob Barker died
this is interesting to me the ethics of
jokes when he was 29 yeah no one's gonna
say like not you know you wouldn't make
any jokes yeah yeah but 99 kind of goes
like good life long life yeah you you
hope but it's weird that when you laugh
you are kind of doing this sort of
checkbook balancing of like is it okay
especially in a group is this okay and
and long age is one of those indicators
yeah it's funny because I I feel like
that's my you know I've been doing my uh
stand up uh it's called J Muse and his
amusing stories and I tell stories more
so than sets but uh my wife was saying
she watches I bet you're great well
thank you well we'll see if you ever see
you'll be like well maybe he wasn't no
but no you know what I was like I
couldn't imagine not being compelling
that's I'm gonna say that right now I
haven't been able to
um figure out that line like I'm always
I've never do play work with people
from the audience because I'm always
worried I'm going to say like I'll watch
people where they're talking about like
they'll say some like pretty racy things
that I'm like
like I feel like I'm worried about doing
that because I always feel like I'm
gonna be the one who's like well you
should have not had so many kids or
whatever and then they're like whoa dude
that's so cool you know and then
everyone's like tweeting about like he
was re you know he made this mom feel
bad right right or whatever I don't know
but just to give you an example so I've
always it's funny you say you make jokes
about people in the audience and they
sometimes make you know yeah um and I'm
again we've watched a couple I have a
friend uh who's who's really funny dude
he's been opening for me for like a year
and a half which he hasn't now he just
opened up for Bert Chrysler Crusher
twice now for like a 10 000 people but I
knew it I knew as soon as I could found
them he won a contest to open up for me
in like Kansas City oh wow and I
afterwards I was like bro do you go on
the road like can you come with me and
open up for me he's like dude that would
be an honor and now like a year later
he's like he's doing really well I knew
it he's really what's his name AJ
Wilkerson
oh yeah yeah
well if you ever get a chance chance
look him up he yeah he's very funny and
he's doing well but the point is why
they say oh but he's he's also sort of
messes with people in the audience and
stuff so it's just funny but I'll watch
him on when we're there and I'll be like
man I'm gonna I'm gonna call these
people out or something but then I
always get like so he's still trying to
figure that out buddy I am too and and
it's not easy for me so I actually I
have jokes where I make fun of my
parents so it's every step there's like
a little joke where I make fun of my
parents and after six shows this weekend
I go back to my sometimes I go back to
my hotel and I'm like what am I doing
you know like you just have this like
vulnerability yeah it's not that the
jokes didn't work you just you're like
you know and they're nice jokes they're
not that mean about my folks but it's
just like I'm I'm up there talking about
my parents there is a cost to it then
there must be a cost to you going up on
stage I'm assuming you talk about
uh your addiction and hard times and
yeah well do you ever get a
vulnerability hangover yeah no I mean I
I feel like I I for me right now is my
as much as I've been doing it I think
there's Stories the good thing is for me
it's like again Kevin and I have been
doing we did our podcast live for so
many years and put them out on you know
afterwards um people could listen but I
feel like I've shared a lot of my stuff
like I really don't hold back much I
don't talk a lot about I still don't
really I sometimes tell sex stories
about me and my wife some funny
situations but it's like I never so so I
don't really I'm an open book I guess
I'm just saying like I see what you're
saying really somebody messaged me once
and they were like how do you because
you know I wrote a book and I talk about
being at ramdas house and really wanting
to jerk off and embarrassing stuff I
like that yeah and they were like how do
you get there and I was like I said what
you said which is like you just practice
and and the more you do it and you see
that the sky doesn't fall yeah whatever
the fantasy is they're all gonna point
at you and it's a shame or whatever it
doesn't happen yeah then you actually I
wouldn't trade it for the world like
being able to say like hey do you have a
small penis and like let's talk about my
weird balls and whatever it is
that to me is there's a spaciousness of
life that when I talk to other people
that are like tight yeah like it's
almost like they're still in high school
and they're like hello I the way I say
it is you ever talk to someone who's on
it who talks like they're on a
conference call and they're not on
account hello Jason how are you yeah
let's Circle back to what we were
talking about it's like we're at coffee
right now and it's because they've been
so steam cleaned they're victims yeah
they really are and you just want to
give them I don't know a week in Hawaii
to run around naked and Howl at the Moon
you know I love it let's break them open
this episode is sponsored by better help
I don't know if you're like me I've got
a very very active brain and very often
thoughts keep me up at night sometimes I
get up to pee I come back to bed and it
just starts flooding out repetitive
unhelpful obsessive thoughts stress
anxiety there's always something to
worry about turns out one great way to
make those racing thoughts go away and I
know this from experience is to talk
them through these are unresolved things
that are begging for our attention and
talk therapy is a wonderful way to
unravel that Web Therapy gives you a
place to do this so you can get out of
your negative thought cycles and find
some mental and emotional peace I've
benefited so much from therapy I always
say it's greater than the sum of its
parts talking to a trained professional
helps in ways that honestly I don't
think we even fully understand it's a
deeply human thing it's a need and it
makes a difference it's got me out of
toxic relationships bad work situations
it's helped me get healthier in my body
because when I clean it up upstairs it
helps me clean up my life in the third
dimension it's a huge coping skill it's
a huge way to set boundaries with family
with friends with work and it empowers
you to be the best version of yourself
so if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule all you do is fill out a brief
questionnaire get matched with a
licensed therapist and you can even
switch therapists anytime for no
additional charge so get a break from
your thoughts with better help visit
betterhelp.com weirdo today for 10 off
your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash weirdo we're also
brought To Us by another product that
has absolutely changed my life for the
better it's a part of my morning routine
here we are on Monday morning I just did
this element element is a delicious
additive it's silly to call it a powder
it's so much more than that that you
pour in your water for me I got this
from Dr huberman every morning I start
with water that has minerals in it we're
talking about magnesium potassium and
sodium to jump start your day it's
incredible for after workouts but it's
also just a part of my routine flooding
my system with that stuff that it's
craving healthy hydration is what we're
talking about an element knows it's not
just about water it's about water plus
electrolytes the problem is so many
things that have electrolytes in them
are crammed with sugar this is zero
sugar I do it when I'm fasting it
doesn't break my fast element is a huge
part of my wellness program part of my
morning routine that I genuinely look
forward to I start it I like their
watermelon salt in the morning sometimes
at night I do their chocolate Salt and I
do it hot like a hot chocolate it's
incredible especially when I'm fasting
feels like I'm giving myself a treat but
like I said I'm flooding my cells with
this very very specific blend it's an
Optimum ratio of sodium potassium and
magnesium for health performance energy
and Recovery because when you're not
hydrated what happens headaches low
energy cramps confusion it sucks so get
yourself something that makes water
taste way better makes me drink more
water which is awesome get it in and
enjoy it and get those elements that you
need lmnt by the way it's not element
it's lmnt they have a fantastic offer
for us just go to drink lmnt
drinkelement.com weird and use promo
code weird checkout and you'll get a
free element sample pack with your order
when you order my friend Ken who's a
long time friend of mine listener to the
podcast he texted me he's like his
element legit I text him back I was like
it is legit and now he sends me pictures
of him drinking it it's [__] it's the
best get it in your daily routine you
will not regret it especially after you
exercise it's a fantastic feeling to get
those things back into your body that
you are craving drink element.com weird
alright everybody let's get back to
Jason
wait did you see why'd you look over
here that's a picture around us right
there and now sorry about uh who is that
so yeah when you went to did you say you
were with him sorry yeah yeah do you
know him I don't oh he's he's a
spiritual team he wrote be here now okay
oh it's my t-shirt okay great so he
wrote a book yeah and and he was a
barrel teacher that he's also the guy
that got kicked out of Harvard Timothy
Leary and ROM Das Richard Alpert like
were the ones that like kind of brought
LSD into
into America oh really okay because it
was legal okay so there was a company
called Santos that they ordered like
they used Harvey it's kind of like this
pretty you know I don't know what you
want to call it but Renegade the story
where they were researchers their
therapists psychotherapists they
discovered LSD Timothy Leary did
mushrooms in Mexico told Richard Albert
about it they Tim Leary's quote about it
was like in his trip
and who knows how strong these mushrooms
were but he was like I experienced like
10 years of therapy in five hours yeah
that was his experience yeah so they're
like we need to look into this so at
some point I think they bought a million
dollars worth of LSD and brought it in
and have you ever heard set and setting
like if you do a psychedelic you got to
be careful of your sentence yes yes like
how you feel and where you are yes
that's them that's their research okay I
mean it sounds silly that somebody had
to figure that out but somebody had to
figure out like yeah it it matters who
you're with where you are how you feel
if you're regulated you know if you're
yeah because I and so so and then on
campus did they wind up giving it to
students
let's do a test here they went goofy
yeah yeah they gave it to grad students
and that was going okay because again it
was legal yeah and they were doing the
research and it was really exciting but
they were here's the I think the two
mistakes according to the board they
made was they did it themselves so they
were also doing it and that's so they
would they said that wasn't good science
yeah yeah and you know
you know obviously I'm going to side
with them I'm like you kind of have to
know what you're talking about yeah and
then two uh they gave they started
giving it to undergraduates and one of
it I I might be getting this wrong but
Andrew wheel have you ever seen that guy
with a big bushy Gray beard he's like a
a holistic medicine yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's always Barefoot he kind of looks
like Rick Rubin but a little I don't
know different shape anyway that guy was
the student that did it and they found
out and that shut it all down so they
both got booted but then ramdas went to
India started giving LSD to uh monks and
like the sadhus the like wandering holy
people yeah he was like what is this
yeah and this is this story is almost
over but like they would take it and
some people were like meditation is
better and he's like excuse me yeah he
was like what and then he gave it to the
man right right over there that's
maharaji up there in the corner you
probably can't see it but that was his
Guru
in uh in India and he gave him something
like 700 milligrams of LSD which is like
seven tabs yeah micrograms and um
nothing happened so he was like
what what's what's going on how could
somebody ingest that much and just be
kind of like hello yeah yeah he was like
he thought he was going to break him
yeah he was worried he was going to
break him he didn't say take 700 he was
like this is all I have and he he just
took all of it but he was trying to show
him that this is my paraphrase that the
the places that those psychedelics are
unlocking are are inside of us like you
can trudge through the snow yourself you
don't need to get a ride there yeah you
can kind of like go in and the point
isn't just pretty colors and stuff it's
to find yeah yeah the essence of being
well I know that they I know that they
are doing
um and like for like drugs for to get
people off drugs too I know there's I
forget there's like a root too that
people take well people on heroin
sometimes take Ayahuasca that's it
Ayahuasca yes yes there's all these
things so it all makes sense but well I
didn't know there was and you went to
see him or is that yeah I sat with him
uh a couple times two separate
um this is a spiritual bragging it's so
stupid I just wanna I just wanna love it
note
uh that that I was privileged to be able
to say with them twice on private
Retreats where we basically just sat
quietly I mean he was in his 80s he had
had a stroke so he wasn't I wasn't he
wasn't like lecturing to me just kind of
hung out and talked and yeah he was very
meaningful to me but I was raised like
Evangelical like kind of fundamentalisty
so he's like you're he's like you're
Stan Lee he's my Stan Lee yeah I like it
yeah that is my stand yeah very nice
it's interesting comic books I have a
lot of that
you know there's a lot of like the
hero's journey and stuff in that where
where are you religiously we usually get
that at the end were you raised in a
certain way and did anybody did comic
books steer you towards yourself you
know no um so I was with my grandma she
was Methodist Baptist uh so she would
she would you know I would go to Sunday
school with her she'd go to church I'd
go in Sunday school and then started
going to church with her on Sundays you
know in the church we would go to like
the priest would bust out of base and be
like blow the trumpet in Zion Zion
sitting alone in the Holy Mountain
it was all it was actually yeah it was
like the whole band like the priest at
the base and then were you with the
callers well no no no
yeah plain clothes officers and music
and stuff so that part I didn't mind
because people would get up me dancing
and yeah yeah yeah
um and then uh but and then they also
also do which I still
don't understand as a kid like I would
see they'd come up and they'd do the oil
and then like you're healed you know and
they'd fall and we they would do the the
hour or hour and a half of sermon and
stuff with people laying all over the
ground being like
you know and they would say that the
demons were leaving their body like they
were being they were being like cleansed
or whatever and I still don't because
it's like for me even as a kid I was
like there's no way they like were like
hey man we're this week you're the one
he's going to be on the ground pretend
sit there for an hour do your thing yeah
but they would sit there for a good hour
like making noises sometimes they'd be
quiet but some of them would be like and
you know they'd speak in tongues and
stuff
um and so it is a phenomenon we can we
can say it's a phenomenon like the the
critic wants to say there's no way they
were involuntarily compelled to do it
but there's I think there's something
about
what's his name Darren Brown is he the
magician can you give that a Google
please Katie there's a guy who does did
this very very interesting show and it's
on Netflix where he did he's like I'm an
atheist I don't believe in any of this
and he then he proceeds to say this is a
healing ceremony when I come back out
we're gonna do like exactly what you're
talking about and he does it all he
tells them it's fake yeah yeah and then
he plays music and he gets people
excited and he uses all the language and
somebody who's raised religious I'm like
getting the chills because it's like
powerful and he and he has people who
like have arthritis and stuff lift 500
pounds or something yeah and he's like
what is going on here so he used it to
be like
this is my assumption on what his point
was look at what nonsense it is it's
just hysteria it's just contagious
enthusiasm or whatever or peer pressure
I looked at it as like
no this seems like there's something
greater than the sum of its parts that's
created when like human beings get
together I'm using more like mythical
language I suppose or it's like you've
kind of proven how magical we are in my
in my language I go look how magical
that is yeah yeah and he's like no it's
just a psychological phenomena and I'm
like you know potato potato yes
because it is amazing yeah like people
did drop their crutches and said did you
find what is called Darren
guy an Illusionist a mentalist yeah
Darren Brown he's truly incredible and I
don't could you maybe find what that
special is called
I think it's called like believe for
Faith or so I don't know it that's my I
remember my ma had me bring her when she
was very sick so she gets out of jail
she she has AIDS she's withering away
and she had me bring and I wish I could
remember the guy's name but it was one
of those healers you know she really she
would watch it where was it it was in
Jersey but it was at like the Coliseum
or whatever
um exit 116 or oh so he had like a
massive yeah yeah you went on tour yeah
and she wanted me to bring her we
brought her because he picks people from
the audience and they come up on stage
in crutches or wheelchair and heals them
and she really was convinced if she
could just get there yeah and he saw her
he would heal her and maybe cure her up
her sickness and he didn't hear no I
didn't you know he didn't get the Sierra
or anything but it's again but it was
her belief she really I feel like deep
down like she believed that she could
get on that stage she would get healed
and there's a real power to that yeah
one of the most uncomfortable Realms of
science science it seems for I don't
know I'm I'm uh being presumptive but
like the placebo effect is the most
interesting thing that none of us are
talking about we give a control group a
sugar pill yeah and we give these people
the real thing and like 70 of the sugar
pill people are like my echinacea is
gone and it's like why the [__] is it
gone now yeah I'm like why the [__] so
there is and it goes back to your lack
of self-esteem it goes back to like
what I'm saying is these agreements that
we're making with ourselves what we
deserve what I'm not this is not the
clip that gets pulled of Pete saying
people are asking for disease I'm saying
the placebo effect suggests that there's
some sort of component that we don't
understand yeah that's not over matter
type of thing what's going on right yeah
and if we were in India would be having
a much more interesting or a much more
comfortable conversation because I would
never want and I'm saying this very
firmly nobody who's sick it's their
fault that is not what I'm saying I'm
saying that there seemed to be people
that are like like Joe dispenza is one
of those guys who had a back problem and
and he like through meditation like went
in and visualized his back fixing itself
read his book don't take my word for it
yeah but he's very interested in the
placebo effect
but I I I know I certainly don't know
what your mom felt I do know what it's
like I had this thing on my hand I had
to get surgery I used to sit and
meditate and imagine my hand getting
better and and it didn't happen yeah it
doesn't what I'm saying is so am I an
idiot because I couldn't heal my hand
certainly not but is he full of [__]
because he did heal his back yeah or or
someone goes on stage and
I guess what we're talking about is the
power of belief yeah yeah yeah like
we were listening like when I believe in
you it matters like if you're about to
go on stage the small example and I say
like I what I said to you I was like
there's no way you can't be compelling
be yourself that helps yeah yeah I know
that as a performer yeah but if you were
like dude you're gonna you're gonna
[__] time yeah it's the Seinfeld
episodes we'll give up the pilots in the
audience and yeah and you just freak out
because the Pilot's in the audience yeah
words are spells yeah and I know that
sounds crazy
and I've said this a million times but
they they have data on like if I use
certain words you behave a different way
yeah if we can affect your behavior I
always my wife and I she start now I
feel like she gets it more but sometimes
she'll get upset because
she used to like not realize and she
might call me before I'm about to get on
stage and be like you know your your
daughters give me a lot of crap and I'm
really upset and I'm like please don't
call me before my show and give me news
that I'm gonna obsess about or think
about I was like well that's selfish I'm
like no no no no no no I'm like I'm
trying to be funny I'm trying to make
everyone laugh yeah she gets it now I'm
just saying like it is same thing though
what you're saying when I did new faces
in Montreal which was a huge huge I
think about this every time I go to
Montreal the con there's a Comedy Fest
there yeah it's a big deal it's a it was
my first big break and my girlfriend at
the time and we laughed about this years
later did a very similar thing she
called me it's like three hours before
my show and she just like was like
panicking and kind of crying something
in her family and I'm on the phone and
I'm just like to be honest I was
breaking up with her in my mind because
I was like you can't this doesn't work
yeah I'm about to go up in front of in
my opinion everyone who matters yes and
you made me worry about no it's true
your dog or whatever it was and
to your greater point and I'm glad that
your wife figured that out Val and I
figured that out and this isn't
performer specific like it's actually
the much more loving thing to do to say
this might not make sense you know it's
not it's not maybe a normal thing but
I'm trying to be in a certain headspace
and in fact that's your job yeah and all
of that news will keep yeah yeah it'll
keep yeah if you're like you know in a
situation right now and I can do
something right now maybe absolutely we
can break the rule but like let's honor
the job yeah so much of my job as a
performer
is carving out allowances for things
that look like Leisure Time like you
know what I mean like I need quiet
somebody just texted me I was in Denver
they texted me they're like uh do you
want to get lunch or do a thing or this
or this and I just wrote back I was like
I don't hang out when I'm on the road
yeah and I was like it's not you I don't
hang out and they were completely
understood but it took me about 20 years
to get to the place yeah people came
into my green room the other day at
Largo and they were like are we
bothering you and I said not yet yeah I
wasn't being an [__] I was just like
not yet this is okay thank you for
asking yeah I was wondering what you do
if we can go all the way back to
something like Clerks
what did you do to get in the mood
because I know
we don't always guys like us talkers you
know emoters you're out there you're
being hilarious and funny how do you get
in the zone to do that you know it's
funny for clerks there was always so no
I didn't plan on doing clerks you know
Kevin and I grew up the same town same
high school and we started hanging out
and he's like hey you have this weird
sense of humor I'm writing a movie and
while I was writing it I wrote a
character based on you for you and we're
going to be filming I saved money I was
like whatever I was putting roofs on
houses at this point and I was like yeah
sure whatever and I really didn't think
anything of it because it wasn't like
now where people are doing podcasts and
you know TB raising money Kickstarter it
was still Fringe it was weird shoulder
camera like you know and wait they shot
clicks on VHS no but okay okay that was
like the only available camera for the
norm yes he went and rented one but I
didn't even know you could do that like
yeah I mean and this was at a time when
it was like okay buddy you know now now
a kid goes I'm making a movie and you're
like you submit it to festivals you know
what I mean like we understand yeah
understand that so it really I didn't
think anything of it and so but when it
came time finally he was like I got the
camera you're gonna come here after we
shut we're going to close the
convenience store when I'm done working
around 10 o'clock at night be here
here's your script and stuff and I just
remember being so nervous and the first
scene we shot I was like you know Olaf
sing Berserker girls think sexy and you
know like it I was so nervous and I like
a scarecrow like you're like planted in
the ground yeah rigid like I had no and
he got a scene partner who doesn't talk
exactly that doesn't help and it's the
director yeah he's smoking and you can
see in his eye that he's like this isn't
going exactly and then so I'm like can
everyone in here so like if we were in a
room like this and there's like you're
the she's camera your sound and he's
here I'd be like can she go in and you
go in and like but Kevin's like dude how
are we gonna run the camera and I'm like
just hit record and run in the room
believe I wanted everyone out of the
quick stop when I filmed when I was
filming unless it was Brian of course if
we were doing a scene I had to do
dialogue with them but I was so nervous
but after the first day
um you know I I did anything I used no
none of the things he had to he had to
do an insert if you go back there's an
insert of me and him using we're like
moving our feet and they had to throw
that in because they couldn't cut back
to me being like Olaf sing Berserker so
he luckily he had done some inserts for
feet you know some sounds to cut away
yeah so he cut away to that but after we
felt after we did that he's like yo take
a couple hours we're gonna shoot this
and so I had to drink a little
Blackberry Brandy and smoke and it made
me ease up a little bit yeah um and so I
got through it luckily yeah but yeah so
and it took even then also and it's like
all right very brand new yeah I'm gonna
need a Blackberry Brandy it wasn't an
old lady store were they at Werther's
there there is a bar right next door and
they sold little pints of blackberry
Brandy it was great oh my God
yeah and even after that if you go back
like then we could do Mall Rats and
again I had to be the studio movie and
they're like Kevin's like you can't be
like that this is a studio movie in this
world
drunk on BlackBerry yeah
both ways won't work because they
insured me you know so that was like
you're insured you can't drink on set
you can't smoke on set and do all that
um so they they didn't even hire me the
first scene I had to do the scene with
the producers watching and on standby
this has been out there so I could
mention it but on standby they had
audition Jays and on standby if I messed
up if I was like snooch to the news on
the first day The Producers were like
he's going home Seth Green's coming in
no [__]
yeah Seth Green had auditioned and they
liked his performance best and he had
done movies and stuff rotate in Seth
Green so now you're performing sober
nervous and with Seth Green's haunting
green eyes in the wings
but again for me it's like I'm joking
I'm just saying like it's a lot of
tensions
and ready to pounce they weren't paying
for my hotel they weren't paying for per
diem the flight Kevin had to put fly me
out to Minnesota I had to sleep on his
floor until the producers saw the first
day of dailies and watched and then
okayed it and then okayed it and thank
goodness I was like I gotta do this I
gotta do this and you know the first
three scenes we shot I still was nervous
but I got through it and I did my best
and they were like all right he's good
we're gonna let him get the [__] out
yeah
those days I mean I really just would
sit there and be like all right and I
would read the script over and over and
over and so you were trying to be Word
Perfect yeah because your performances
always seem and this is a compliment
they seem like you're just talking yeah
well because again
yeah everything written stuff so for
clerks mole rats Chasing Amy is pretty
much those years of me saying things
doing things and him writing down
remembering right Eve and even on like
as I got older and things happened
clerks too you know like
um clerks too for example when I do the
talk and do this and he plays goodbye or
it's because I was I had just found out
who sang that song cute Lazarus and I
burnt the CD and I had that I had my
mixtape and every time Kevin would pick
me up to go somewhere
um I'd put the CD in it would be like
goodbye horse but and and since I've
known him I've always like he would be
like I'll be right back I'm gonna use
the bathroom and I'd like pull my pants
on and Tuck and he'd come in I'd be like
what's up bro you're like dude what are
you doing I'm like sneeze to the news
you know
so I had I so so I had always been
tucking and doing weird stuff and then
at the point when he was writing clerks
too I I had played two Lazarus over over
and over so in his head he popped boom
I'm gonna have Jay outside and he's
gonna put on the music box and be like
you know so and I had really gotten
arrested for a deployed airbag we I mean
my girlfriend were driving to Newark New
Jersey we got into an accident not too
bad that the car couldn't drive but the
airbag blew up we pushed it down we go
buy drugs in the projects we're driving
home we get pulled over and we get
arrested and so when Kevin wrote the guy
comes up he goes hey man where you guys
been and
um and I'm like yo man we've spent six
months in rehab for a deployed airbag
that really happened and Kevin wrote it
in the script so so that was the cool
thing is Kevin's been writing my voice
and and changing and yeah you know
reboots about me being a fault Jay and
buff Jay finds out he's the father
because I actually just had a kid at
Logan you know it's very loving it's
great it's everybody would love to have
a witness that like a priest appreciates
your essence like it's not just
we got six months of rehab for a
deployed airbag
there's a lot of people that would hear
that and not think I mean there's
millions of people that would hear that
a lot of them wouldn't even think it was
funny a lot of them would think it was
funny and then like it seems like one
guy would think it was funny and write
it down like a very special person yeah
yeah so it like it's sort of like graced
you with this does it feel loving to you
100 no yeah he's it's been years again
that's why the great thing it's been 30
years we've been friends and even longer
friends sorry but but over 30 years
being friends and he continues to right
you know he wrote me in all his movies
um and he's always looked at like when
I've been messed up he threw me in rehab
we're going to be doing this movie you
know and and it's like you can't be
doing this movie if you're strung out so
he put me in helped me get in rehab uh
but yeah that's that purpose remember
when I was saying in the village if we
need you to go get fish yeah you can't
be on heroin yeah there is something
about like
like a big thing with Homeboy Industries
so that's the gang rehab yeah a lot of
it is get these guys jobs get these men
and women jobs get them purpose get them
something to do and it makes a huge
difference the fact it used to be called
before was called homeboy it was called
jobs for a future because that was like
I that was their guess or their I bet if
people have work something to do 100
yeah there's just less hopelessness yeah
because it's tough when you take out
especially because it's not even when
you're when you're using and you're
strung out really strung out it's like
not even just you take away the drugs
and now your mind's firing full capacity
and stuff but you also you spend so much
time with the ritual of like I said
after you get strung out you wake up
you're like what am I going to do today
I'm going to get sick and I don't have
any money so maybe I can sell this and
we'll drive it to the pawn shop and then
after the pawn shop if they take it
whatever we have we'll call the dealer
and maybe we'll meet him here and
that'll probably get us through the
night and your days consist of like
survival drugs it's sober it's weird
because you you almost missed that
ritual you're happy in the same way you
can miss prison yeah the structure of
prison yeah so it's it it yeah so that
they have a job makes such a difference
because you have something else to pour
that intensity into 100 absolutely your
shoes were in my dream last night right
well nice thank you there you know I got
these for uh can I tell you yeah I don't
mean that the Santa brag braggy thing go
ahead actually wrote down here crazy
gift story
um oh I got a good one
but these were and it's funny that you
say that because it ties into the same
person so I bought these and got these
because I went got to go to the wedding
of Ben and Jennifer oh wow yeah so we
got invited to go to Savannah and go to
the wedding
um and to me it was exciting because Ben
and you know I've worked with Ben a
bunch
but that's the thing it's like we're
friends but again he he was dating got
married had kids and then now he's with
the new got married again
um you know and I have kids and so we
don't it's not like I talk to him every
day or every week or month even like
sometimes I haven't seen him or talked
to him in six months or whatever but
anyway so I bought these and I bought
them for the wedding I wore them at the
wedding and then I put in my closet so
that's why they're like nice and I want
to have a pair of these that are
completely new because I love these
shoes yeah this is good I have the white
wedding sneakers and I'm honored that
you wore them today sir
ship so in a way I'm Ben Affleck and
Katie's JLo is that safe to say
I actually wrote down after like I'm a
huge Affleck fan so let me tell you
about my gift then okay so he goes okay
so so
when uh so at one point I was hanging
out with Ben a little more and um we
were spending time I actually lived at
his house for a little bit when I got
out of rehab didn't Kevin live at his
house too well Kevin bought his house
years later that's what it is and owned
it for 20 years he actually just moved
it must be fun to Hardware Affleck yeah
well the cool thing was fun for me is I
got the far where Affleck farted and I
got the fart where Kevin lives it's
funny because I Kevin's bedroom had this
huge eight-person tub and I remember
when he's like I came over the first
time and he moved in it yeah but it's
like it's not a Jacuzzi there's like a
tub but I had I got to make love in it
right so I'm like I made love here I had
a little sex there I had a little sex
there before Kevin even did even though
he owned the house and I was like ha ha
Isaac my balls touch his toilet before
yours you know
um but um so when we were hanging a
bunch
you know you know he's a Ben's a huge uh
Red Sox fan yeah and I'm a Yankees fan
I'm not huge in the baseball don't get
me wrong but growing up in Jersey yeah I
always like Yankees I went to the
Yankees game it's a cool hat yes yeah
and it's a cool hat yes I mean how much
does that help if you had the Hat of
like the 1986 Pirates I don't think it
would be the franchise it is today it
was no it was it you know and then I
then I changed it up for the Sharks had
a really cool hat they do and that was a
very 90s hip yes or maybe even early
yeah because they just came out yeah so
so I make it so it's I forget which
series it was but it was like a big
seven game series Yankees versus Red Sox
and um I'm like yo Yankees are gonna
Crush socks and uh and he's like you
want to make a bet I'm like yeah I was
like what's the bet I bet he said that
Dead series oh he was like there was no
humor in that and he's so he that was
scary athletic he had uh this really
nice GXXR 1000 and motorcycle that I
really loved and that was his and then
he had a couple other motorcycles but
I'm like if I win the bet how about you
give me that bike he's like all right
and he's like well what do I get if you
lose I was like I don't know I was like
I'll get a tattoo of the Red Sox symbol
on my body and he's like no you won't I
was like I will and so so
game happens I lose the BET yes you
can't see it now I've covered it up but
you can store it you can see it yeah I
can see it so wait was that a clause in
there like you can't cover up the the
bee for a couple years yeah it was yeah
yeah wait you banged it out we're
lawyers yeah yeah not really that's so
funny I can kind of I wouldn't have seen
it but yeah so I got the B so I lose the
BET and he's like you lost man you got
to get a tattoo but he didn't push me on
it he wasn't like dude you getting it
today you're getting it today he's just
like you got to get the tattoo and then
he laughed about it and walked away and
I don't think he thought anything of it
honestly but a couple days later me and
my buddy that was working for him and
helping him out whatever him and I go to
the tattoo shop I get the Red Sox tattoo
I come back I'm like look I told you I'd
get it he's like I cannot believe you
did he laugh and he laughed about it and
he couldn't believe I did it he's like
you're crazy you didn't have to get it
really and I was like well now you tell
me but he's like listen you got to keep
that for a couple that's a good story
it's a good story but here's even a
better story
so then I'm like man I was like he's
like I can't believe you went through
with it this isn't like whatever month I
I don't know Christmas was close I know
that when is I don't know if you guys
know when baseball ends let's just
pretend that's the month of I don't know
October exactly so November December a
couple months from Christmas
so I do the bet I get the thing he can't
believe it all sudden I come to his
house Christmas day or the day after
Christmas I come over I was like hey
Merry Christmas good to see you I'm
going to do this this and this and I
want my buddy that works with them and
all of a sudden he goes come here I got
something for you for Christmas I go
what he goes come downstairs if we go
out downstairs we go outside he opens up
the garage and a Christmas bow on the
GSXR because I went through the bet he
gave me the motorcycle for Christmas
anyway oh my God that is so nice my mom
it's like a Bible story it's amazing
tattoo and I gave him the bike anyway
for being a good son it was amazing
serious I was so that's your gift thing
yeah dude look at the look at the card
it says Affleck here it says name drop
sometimes I say tell me a name droppy
story but right under that is crazy gift
so we got Affleck and crazy gift right
there and it happened and a name job too
and the name drop I'll tell you another
thing
the name
yes you know what it says their party
I'm gonna count it because it was
Christmas yes it was I love it I love it
I love it so yeah it was again it was it
his biker did he get you it was his it
was his okay that's even more meaningful
it was it really was because it was
again it was exactly the bike because he
had another bike
two that like was really cool that I
mean he had a couple at the time and
that's the one he knew I wanted and he
gave it to me which was very sweet wow
and doesn't he have a crazy tattoo on
his back
you know I know he got that years and
years later and I don't think I've ever
talked about it no and I've never seen
this isn't even that kind of podcast I
just I know people he was like a meme or
something and I was kind of like I want
to know the story but it's a cool story
yeah I forget I think someone had
mentioned this story and I don't
remember I don't remember what it was
for exactly yeah maybe one of those
movies or something but yeah yeah it
doesn't matter no it doesn't I'm So Pro
athletic it's not like is it something
sad or weird and it wasn't even that
what about
no dude you don't even have to tell any
more stories except hold a bunch right
no that's what I'm saying here man
I have to put another quarter in this
jukebox no it's good what is the thing
you wanted to promote because you're
you're right yeah you represented that
you had some giveaway or something yes
yeah where's my phone sorry yeah yeah oh
I'm going to cheat and use my phone no I
want you to use it I had so much fun I
almost forgot about this so yes we are
doing a cruise it's gonna be the uh I
want to say a nice word for word I was
gonna just try to spit it out I want you
to read it yeah so if you've already had
your Seth Green waiting in the wings
experience the rest of your life can be
nice and easy okay so this is going to
be the cruise SQ giveaway
um enter your chance to win a balcony
cabin for two on a Cruise's SKU
um it's uh the the enter to win it's
snuggins at I mean dot T bits dot me
that's
s-n-o-o-g-a-n-s dot T bits b-i-t-s dot
me the winner will be notified by uh on
sorry it will be notified on October
13th 2023. yeah travel to from uh so
getting to Miami because it's gonna be
from Miami to the Bahamas
um at the Nassau Bahamas on the
luxurious Norwegian Pearl is the name of
the boat so that's February 23rd through
the 26th of 2024 but you can't you have
to get yourself to the port like Miami
and what is this when you say we're
doing a cruise so let me tell you join
me and Kevin Smith and all of our ice
Universe friends foreign too skinny
Kevin Smith does it say that no it
doesn't come join me in two skinny Kevin
Smith he posted on Instagram and I was I
almost commented like I'm gonna send you
a sandwich man you are so he looks 19
years old
Brian and Jeff we're gonna be there
that's a trip packed with
um that's going to be the reading of
Clerks three the original oh so Kevin
wrote clerks three and then like
um covet happened and so when he was
talking to Jeff and Brian hey like when
it's when hopefully eventually we get
back to making movies I want to do he
said uh Jeff was like you know what I
like the script but I really think this
is I think you should make some changes
Kevin wrote a whole nother clerks three
script which you see in the movie Clerks
three that if you saw clerks three
that's the movie Kevin wrote but there's
a whole nother script there's a secret
script there's a secret script clerks
three that he wrote before he actually
rewrote the whole script again and so
there's all different things like it's a
totally different script and we're going
to read a pro-religious Dogma as well
and yeah so they're gonna head up so
there's gonna be script reading of
Clerks three and Mallrats live podcasts
stand-up comedy
Kevin Smith me Museum so Kevin's
bringing a bunch of his stuff for a
museum yeah there's going to be a movies
pop-up restaurant movies if you guys
know the movies uh Kevin had to come up
with a fake restaurant because he
couldn't use Burger King or you know oh
yeah and so clerks too the guys work at
Movies
um movies The Cow movies so there's cool
stuff like hater tots [__] smoker which
is a chicken sandwich and stuff like
that so it's gonna be a movies pop up
um and we're going to be doing uh
tournaments like I'm gonna be doing some
video game tournaments some poker
tournaments I'm doing my amusing stories
on there AJ Wilkerson Jake rule will be
there the gentleman yeah you guys
talking about
um Soul Asylum is going to be performing
there oh no way runaway training yeah
yeah are they Jersey it's rain never
come back yeah they were in there
seems like I'm always getting somewhere
somehow I mean I can't know them
I know what no one else can know
no one else can go I'll also I just got
booked yes
I mix it
it's interesting I badly sing runaway
train even though Soul Asylum is here
what would you do if soul song was like
hey I saw the podcast and I said I want
you to come on I want you to come on the
ship and you're gonna sing that song
from beginning to end oh my God I'd be
so nervous because I want to be good at
things so I'd be like I can't I can't
one time I say they're like we'll give
you a million dollars
[Laughter]
um there's gonna be a gambling of pokers
tournaments and stuff and gambling
um I feel like I'm missing something
because uh we're doing the museum we're
doing the podcast we're doing uh like
Hollywood babylon's gonna be on there uh
I think Mark Bernard is a lot I'm not
saying wrap it up I love it people are
in people are in it say the website one
more time I'm gonna say that one more
time
turning it down as I sing Soul Asylum
all right they're like oh my god
um all right the last time I will say
you can
enter at
noogans dot
t-bits.me okay so
snugand.tbits dot me or you can if you
have trouble and you forget also
um
twitch I want to promote this too I
stream on Twitch twitch.tv forward slash
j-a-y Muse J Muse
um My Stream almost every day I've been
doing that
m-e-w-e-s yes m-e-w-e-s I love it it's
one of the things I've been doing you
game on it so yeah play video games you
unbox things fortnite Call of Duty Apex
party animals which is this really fun
game with these dogs that run around
um but I I it's it's been fun I've been
doing it for like three years and yeah I
enjoy it but I might uh so yeah so if
you get a chance follow me on that
um it's free to follow and hang out and
I sometimes do q and A's on there that's
great
um you know and and it's fun two last
questions yes one is a weird one yes
you're
Kevin is right you're no one is like you
I'm also just curious I was like is
Pauly Shore like a thing for you because
when I think about anybody that was like
in movies being so purely themselves and
so purely silly yeah you know like
there's a snoochibuchi weasel kind of
parallel I just wondered if he meant
anything to you he does and let me tell
you uh we're gonna end on this great
story so man you also sound a little
like Duncan Trestle has anyone ever told
you that
um no who do you know Duncan no I'll
tell you about them all right he's great
so Paulie yes Paulie a big fan of
Paulie's growing up it's well you know
for years and then my mom was a huge fan
when she was sick and she was in those
last few years she would watch his
movies over him and Chris Farley over
and over and over again sweetest thing
is I'm out in L.A and I don't remember
how but I crossed paths with him
um and he comes out we chat we exchange
numbers I tell him how much my mom loves
him and he winds up calling me one day
out of the blue and goes let me talk to
your mom and he sent talk to my mom for
like a half hour uh made her day and
then he sent her all this stuff and was
so sweet and it was the sweetest thing
ever and then he's like bro when you
come out again if you need to you could
stay at my place and when I came out the
next time I didn't I stayed at his place
for a couple days and he drove me around
and showed me some places and I got to
meet I remember it's so funny because
I'm like again this is like I'm like a
jersey kid didn't really hang out here
and meet many people except for working
a little bit in the beginning
um but also I'm at his house and like
carrot comes the pizzastic pick
something up and I was like this is so
weird like just weird little things like
that but even me being and Paulie's
house was like so surreal because again
I watched his movies with my mom when
she was sick and she loved them and
anyway I thought it was the sweetest
thing but uh but yeah and then later on
I did a little Cameo I didn't Cameo I
guess it would be in his movie Paulie's
sure is dead or something yeah movie
which is weird because you and here are
two people that people presume dead yes
exactly yeah yeah
um so very nice guy you have sex in his
a person bathtub or no he didn't get
that that was mine that was because you
would definitely not be the first person
like this is my place
um but yeah so it was he's very nice and
it's it's funny because again these are
two people that like again and he's not
someone I sit in chit chat with
constantly but yeah it's nice because he
like did that way back for me uh and
talked to my mom
um and throughout he's like he'll like
hit me up and say hey how you been how
are things and all that I've only met
him once or twice but he's always very
sweet yeah yeah it's cool man that's
great well that is a great story to end
on well thank you and thank you for
doing yes thank you you know Val listens
to you and Kevin's party that's my wife
podcast and I went he's a podcaster and
I was like it's going to be great I
already knew you were going to be great
but you're such a pro thank you and if
the producers were watching Seth Green
you can go home now yeah thank you you
can go home JK we love you
[Music]
um would you say keep it crispy it's
just our little catchphrases right here
you do it however I see Jay Muse keep it
crispy no that's no just do it just your
voice yeah yo keep it crispy snooch to
the news
I didn't know
I didn't know I really wanted you to say
snitch to the news well thank you but
then you did thank you
are you [__] me I thought you were
like well we need to have it on the job
no no no no that's what we wanted thanks
perfect that was awesome
[Music]